in your mind what is the end goal for
bitcoin is it to become the global
reserve currency like where do you see
it ending up in 10 years 20 years 30
years right bitcoin becomes essentially
the global reserve currency because uh
it just pushes everything else out
there's nothing that can compete with it
and people want to use it as money and
as a store of value and that's what
dictates ultimately
the the market it'll be a unit of
account everybody will think in bitcoin
what does this cost me in bitcoin what
does this car cost me in bitcoin what
does this how much bitcoin am i earning
in this job like even if they have a
local currency that's different that's
true what are the obstacles to get there
the obstacles to get toward hyper
bitcoinization on a global basis
uh are uh the entrenched oligopoly that
is not keen on giving up their
position
and uh the thing about bitcoin is that
it's a peaceful revolution it's not a
violent revolution unlike any other
revolution in the past has been a
violent revolution with bitcoin it's all
you need to do is adopt and use bitcoin
uh to be part of the revolution and as
the use grows as price goes up
everything that we know about it uh and
it squeezes out the weak hands it
squeezes out the weaker economies the
weaker minds the weaker and it acts like
a mirror and it exposes people like paul
krugman or somebody like that who's a
public intellectual uh others other
economists who are uh
like naseem tele was an amazing case of
someone who had an incredible reputation
and within three or four months it
became completely trashed
because the bitcoin mirror showed us
that this guy was intellectually
dishonest at some level and it got
crushed by it
um and so this is this is this happens
across the spectrum with other
economists other intellectuals other
monetary theories uh like stacy was
saying it's an excellent point typically
in the central america it's a choice
between military dictatorship and
socialism
and either side of that coin is doesn't
work you know this is the third option
this is the third way this is the vector
out this is the bitcoin way and it gets
it demonetizes both it it gets rid of
both it's a preferential way it's
controlled entirely by the individuals
who have that uncomplicatable wealth
that the private key that can't be taken
away from them and that encourages a
behavior in the community you know i say
you don't change bitcoin bitcoin changes
you and you see that in el salvador
where the president is thinking big he's
thinking in new ways he's thinking let's
bring all these people here he's getting
the benefit of that of that bitcoin
philosophy that bitcoin thinking that
that comes with it beyond just the fact
that its number go up you see you see
bitcoin changing him you see bitcoin
change michael saylor you see bitcoin
change us you see bitcoin change
everybody so i
everybody's on their own journey
only you can do you you know you can
approach the rabbit hole in any way that
is unique to you but we all end up at
the same place which is hyper
bitcoinization yeah i think that's what
for me the key to bitcoin maximalization
or bitcoin maximalist is that the
recognition that there is this one point
on the horizon that everyone's kind of
going toward and to deny that is just
wasting everyone's time just understand
that we're all kind of heading into that
one global hyperbolization bitcoin
standard point on the horizon we're on
this pilgrimage together
toward this this this outcome and that's
bitcoin maximalization and for those who
argue against it
i i i'm there everyone's happy to argue
against it but i i no one's made a
compelling case that that what i just
said is not true uh they make very
pedantic cases they make very circular
logical kind of runarounds and trolling
cases that go nowhere
and we've all seen them the fiat world i
think has like a social credit score
mentality so you're kind of brought up
to be very suburban
and be very polite and very nice to
somebody just because they smile at you
and
for me personally and i can only speak
for myself like that sort of toxic
maximalism just
saves me from having to be nice to
somebody just because i i've known them
for 10 years and now they have a [ __ ]
coin that they you know and it just
helps to like okay i just uh don't
i i
how do i get over the fact that i just
want to be polite and say oh hey that's
cool
glad for you you know it's just like
it's a weight it's a self-defense
mechanism
maybe
you know some people
are different they they could easily
like not be polite and still not be
toxic you know what i mean but i can let
me ask uh two questions so one of the uh
things that happens in the fiat world is
that you have dollars dollars are uh the
reserve uh currency from a medium
exchange store value it's also the unit
of account that people use and the game
if you will in the fiat world is to earn
dollars or get acquired dollars somehow
to then take them invest them
grow in dollar terms and then go back
into dollars right so it's just the
acquisition of more and more and more
dollars yeah when you think of bitcoin
is there a world where you would say
okay we want to acquire bitcoin whether
we're buying it we're earning it however
we acquire it you then invest the
bitcoin into other things whether it's
equities or real estate or whatever with
the hope of acquiring more bitcoin and
going back into bitcoin or is the
thought process that's the biggest
already compounding at an incredible
rate per year over like over 150 correct
and so anytime you step off bitcoin your
risk profile goes up and it goes up
dramatically
and if you're in any way not even
able to handle managing risk which is
the case for 99.9 of the population out
there are very bad at handling a risk
because it gets very emotional this idea
of i'm going to step out make some money
and then step back in it almost in all
cases doesn't work because you're going
to step out you're going to lose
and then you're going to be in a
situation where now what do i do and
most people like this is the this is
called the gambling industry right this
is las vegas if you go into the a floor
in a las vegas casino and you ask 100
people how are they doing and they'll
say i'm winning and you know that's
false they're all losing
and that's that's that's the problem is
that the risk reward on bitcoin is so
incredibly good that to step off that uh
bitcoin into anything else is you're
you're bringing on
a lot of risk that you don't need to
because you're already compounding at
this incredible rate per year so why
even take on any risk and that went that
way yeah so it's like 170 percent i
think right now compound annual growth
rate overlapping right so why why would
you step off that you know so let's say
that bitcoin continues on this path of
hyper bitcoinization which every d you
know every kind of uh underlying
fundamental every single data point we
have seems like that's the general
direction how long it takes up for
debate but that's where we're going kind
of your point there's this like north
star that is the the culmination point
when we get there
the idea would be that bitcoin is quote
unquote stable right one bitcoin equals
one bitcoin and so therefore everything
is priced in bitcoin et cetera
does your opinion change once we get to
that point so right now you're getting
kind of the monetization of bitcoin very
opposite of the demonetization of gold
and so you're getting this priced into
the world the world's trying to figure
out how much is uh a decentralized kind
of transparent central bank with a
programmatic monetary policy that's
literally protected by millions of
people around the world what's that
worth right now the world thinks it's
worth a trillion dollars i think that
everyone in this room thinks it's worth
way more than that in the future but
we'll see how that happens do we reach a
point where there's stability and then
you have to go back to the thinking of
investing bitcoin to earn more bitcoin
no okay because
the end game on bitcoin is something
very very interesting very remarkable
and if you notice pomp you know you and
i have been in this for a while
that there is a whole school now bitcoin
philosophy and bitcoin
kind of um
you know deep thinking that that that
people like robert breedlove and others
get into it uh michael saylor touches on
it
i think that where we're heading here is
where we start to really have a
different thought about what is wealth
and what is
my purpose here on planet earth and
where the idea of that pursuit
of of wealth and that constant
calculation that people are making this
is risk this is not risk i get a little
bit here i get a little bit there i got
my portfolio i got my multiple income
streams i got this going on i think that
that there's a fundamental shift because
you're monetizing people's
better nature in and you're coming out
of a period many many thousand year
period where we're monetizing people's
worst aspects people's greed
has been transformed by bitcoin into
altruism into something that's mutually
beneficial for everyone and when you
have that happen in society the people
are going to step out and just say you
know what i just want to stay here play
my flute raise a garden of zucchinis and
you know i'm not i'm just want to be me
i just want to be cosmically uh
one with who i am as a human being and i
want to look at the stars and i just i
don't just leave me alone um i think
that that's the outcome toward a
hyperbitcoinization of
that that when you have that moment of
almost as a species without getting too
off the range here but almost as a
species it's almost like an evolutionary
step change where we
finally put down the childish toy
of our egos and our need to
get more and more and more
and and we join
we join our into a more of a communal
uh high that's the time preference the
shift in time preference that's that's
that's what the rabbit hole is all about
so so the skills that people have that
are thinking you know i have skills in
hustling i have skills as an
entrepreneur there's a bitcoin thread of
thought that says that no matter what i
do bitcoin is going to keep going up
anyway well am i ever going to be able
to use my skills and the answer is no
you won't you we're all going to go to a
place where people are essentially going
to be in a different completely
different place now obviously there's no
way to the only way we can know this is
going to happen is to actually lift
through and see if it's going to happen
and it what's the timing on this and it
all depends on how fast the dollar
collapses i think that's the linchpin to
the whole
the whole puzzle you know you need the
dollar to really collapse to move us
beyond everything you associate with the
dollar in the post-world war ii global
hegemony and the
the the model of hyper consumption you
know 70 of the us economy's consumption
and yet also you have incredibly high
rates of
prozac and xanax and oxycontin and
stress and disorder and dysfunction
right it's not a happy society people
generally are miserable